dans cette boutique de bonbons situé
dans le centre commercial sqy ouest à
montigny le bretonneux des centaines de
kilos de friandises sont vendus chaque
jour en cette période d'halloween c'est
je pense fondamental dans cette fête il
ya l'idée de se faire plaisir
il ya l'idée d'offrir de donner de
donner gratuitement généreusement si
j'ose dire
halloween est l'emblème le symbole c'est
effectivement la confiserie pour les
enfants selon les enfants cette année
sera particulière pour fêter halloween
ou pas faire la chasse aux bonbons
pourquoi dans
pascal au virus tu as parfois d'autres à
la place là je vais faire un ropa
d'alcon et les confiseries seront bien
sûr sur toutes les tables le magasin une
centaine de références spécialement pour
halloween serpent vert souris ou encore
tête de mort vous pouvez même piéger vos
convives avec des bonbons cerise au
piment
c'est avec goût de la cerise qualifiant
à oui alors ça goût de la cerise moi
j'adore la cerise et le piment derrière
qui arrive c'est très fort mais c'est
bon moi j'aime bien pimentée c'est
surprenant même franchement c'est
l'apprentissage mangin bonbons piments
et le best-seller de cette année les
yeux trop me c'est un bonbon rond
gélatineux en forme de publier en forme
d'oeil et quand vous le croquer à
l'intérieur il ya une main coulis acide
qui se répondent dans votre bouche qui
donne l'impression de croquer un oeil un
véritable et s'est il fait un carton
halloween est la deuxième période la
plus importante de l'année après noël
pour ce magasin